Does that mean this thing is going to be a function? Maybe. Does it mean it's going to be a function template? Is it going to be a Lambda? Is it going to be a variable template lambda or a generic Lambda? These are all possibilities that I don't know and I don't really care at the point where I'm just thinking about the API. So at some level, I have to just play with the API, not really.
这意味着它会是一个函数吗？也许吧。这意味着它会是一个函数模板吗？它会是一个 Lambda 吗？它会是一个变量模板 Lambda 还是泛型 Lambda？这些都是我不知道的可能性，而且在我只考虑 API 的时候，我并不真正关心这些。所以在某种程度上，我必须试着去使用这个 API，其实也不尽然。
Of course I have, like I said, some idea of what's implementable and what's not. but sometimes I just, there's a problem and I want it to be a certain way. And I don't know yet whether I can actually implement that, right? But I write the API that way anyway, and then I have to play around to see what's possible. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 273 recorded on February 4, 20206. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about recreational algorithms, the Chinese number system, pedmas, George Orwell, and more. And sometimes you're playing around, you know, I play around a lot just to, because most of the code I write, a lot of the code I write, I'm very concerned with writing APIs, right? And I want to make the APIs good. I want to make them easy to use. I want to make them sort of natural. I want my team to have a easy time and a good time using them and not have any pitfalls, right? And so I think about how to structure APIs. And I'd like to write wishful thinking code, right?
当然，正如我所说，我对什么是可实现的、什么是不可实现的有一些想法。但有时我只是遇到一个问题，我希望它以某种特定的方式呈现。我还不知道我是否真的能实现它，对吧？但我还是那样写了 API，然后我必须进行尝试，看看什么才是可能的。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，这是 2020 年 2 月 4 日录制的第 273 期节目。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起聊聊娱乐算法、中文数字系统、运算优先级（PEMDAS）、乔治·奥威尔等等。有时你只是在尝试，你知道，我经常尝试，因为我写的大部分代码，我写的很多代码，我非常关注 API 的编写，对吧？我希望 API 很好用。我希望它们易于使用。我希望它们看起来很自然。我希望我的团队在使用它们时感到轻松愉快，并且不会遇到任何陷阱，对吧？所以我思考如何构建 API。我喜欢写那种“愿望清单式”的代码，对吧？
I start out writing the client code for the API, if you like, right? I'm like, what do I want the calling code to look like? And at that point, I am not really concerned with, I'm much less concerned with what's actually possible than what I want it to look like, right? I'm not concerned with thinking about the implementation so much as thinking about the API at that point. And I just sort of have to trust sometimes that it'll be implement.
我从编写 API 的客户端代码开始，如果你愿意的话，对吧？我在想，我希望调用代码看起来是什么样的？在那个时候，我并不真正关心，我远没有那么关心实际上什么才是可能的，而是关心我希望它看起来是什么样的，对吧？在那个时候，我并不关心思考实现，而是更多地思考 API。有时我只能相信它最终是可以实现的。
implementable, right? And so I'm making decisions like, or making choices and sort of observations about things like, well, when I call this, is what I call it with going to be available? At compile time or at runtime, is it going to be something on the past a template argument or a regular function argument? Do I want it to, you know, and I sort of have in my mind a ton of sort of implementation toolkit, if you like. But there's things like, you know, I'm calling this thing. Does that mean? mean this thing is going to be a function, maybe? Does it mean it's going to be a function template? Is it going to be a Lambda? Is it going to be a variable template lambda or a generic lambda?
可实现，对吧？所以我正在做决定，或者说在做选择，并对一些事情进行观察，比如，当我调用这个东西时，我用它调用的东西在编译时还是运行时可用？它是要传递一个模板参数还是一个常规函数参数？我希望它……你知道，我脑子里有一大堆实现工具包，如果你愿意的话。但有些事情，比如，我正在调用这个东西。这意味着什么？这意味着它会是一个函数吗，也许吧？这意味着它会是一个函数模板吗？它会是一个 Lambda 吗？它会是一个变量模板 Lambda 还是泛型 Lambda？
These are all possibilities that I don't know and I don't really care at the point where I'm just thinking about the API. So at some level I have to just play with the API, not really, you know, of course I have, like I said, some idea of what's implementable and what's not. But sometimes I just there's a problem and I want it to be a certain way and I don't know yet whether I can actually implement that. But I write the API that way anyway and then I have to play around to see what's possible. In C++, this really is the great thing, right?
这些都是我不知道的可能性，而且在我只考虑 API 的时候，我并不真正关心这些。所以在某种程度上，我必须试着去使用这个 API，其实也不尽然，你知道，当然，正如我所说，我对什么是可实现的、什么是不可实现的有一些想法。但有时我只是遇到一个问题，我希望它以某种特定的方式呈现，我还不知道我是否真的能实现它。但我还是那样写了 API，然后我必须进行尝试，看看什么才是可能的。在 C++ 中，这确实是一件很棒的事情，对吧？
There are tons of ways to implement anything and there are lots of concerns and trade-offs and things you might want to do. And a lot of times you just have to play to find the right formulation, especially, I think, when it comes to APIs. So is that a form of recreational algorithms when you're playing around with an API,
实现任何东西都有无数种方法，而且有很多顾虑、权衡和你想做的事情。很多时候，你只需要去尝试找到正确的表达方式，尤其是当涉及到 API 时，我认为更是如此。那么，当你摆弄 API 时，这算是一种娱乐算法吗？
or is that different kind of, like, playful? Yeah, I don't know. To me, it's all kind of the same thing, but, you know, it's not really algorithms in a sense. Most of my day job doesn't involve number crunching these days. I do almost exclusively I.O., right? So it's just like, you know, every computer program does two things. Mathematics and I.O.
还是说那是另一种，比如，好玩的东西？是的，我不知道。对我来说，它们都差不多，但你知道，从某种意义上说，这并不是真正的算法。我现在的日常工作大部分不涉及数字运算。我几乎只做 I/O，对吧？所以就像，你知道，每个计算机程序都做两件事：数学和 I/O。
Well, almost every. Some only do I.O. Once that only do mathematics are efficient heaters, I suppose, or not very efficient heaters, maybe. But at the end, you have to do a bunch of algorithms until you get the data into a form you want to print out. You know, some programs do that. But the programs I write on embedded systems almost do 95% IO. Not very much mathematics. they're all about shunting signals around.
嗯，几乎每个程序都是。有些只做 I/O。那些只做数学运算的程序，我想它们是高效的加热器，或者说是不太高效的加热器，也许吧。但最终，你必须做一堆算法，直到你把数据变成你想要打印出来的形式。你知道，有些程序是这样做的。但我编写的嵌入式系统程序几乎 95% 都在做 I/O。没有太多的数学运算，它们全都是关于信号的调度。
I see. So that's why you're focusing mostly on API design at that point. It's not. Yeah, that's what I do most of the time these days. And what informs, I guess, in that vein, what you want your API to look like. This kind of gets back to the philosophy of software design episodes we had where we were talking about, you know,
我明白了。所以这就是为什么你那时主要专注于 API 设计。不是的。是的，这就是我这些天大部分时间在做的事情。那么，在这种思路下，是什么决定了你希望 API 看起来是什么样的？这又回到了我们之前讨论过的软件设计哲学那一期，我们当时在谈论，你知道，
I think for you, you maybe have a more articulated list of things in your head Whereas for me, I don't even realize they're there until someone asks me some specific question and then I'm actually, well, there's like five different things that I'm checking off in my head, but I... Yeah, there's a whole laundry list, right? All kinds of things. Like, you know, at some level, definitely machine sympathy comes into API design, right? You don't want to knowingly create an API which is pessimal.
我想对你来说，你脑子里可能有一份更清晰的清单，而对我来说，直到有人问我具体问题时，我才意识到它们的存在，然后我实际上是在想，嗯，我脑子里有五件不同的事情在核对，但我……是的，有一长串清单，对吧？各种各样的东西。比如，你知道，在某种程度上，机器同理心肯定会进入 API 设计，对吧？你不想故意创建一个极其低效的 API。
You want to have a chance of being optimal. So there's some of that, right? Of course, that comes in C++, because that's the... reason why we write C++. Also, you know, domain sympathy, right? People coming to this with domain knowledge. You want to use the terms they're familiar with. You want to use them in the way they're familiar with. You don't, you don't, it's rare that you can come to a domain, just impose your own fresh view on it with all their own new terms and have people embrace that. People still complain about the UI in Git, for example, right? Does Git have a UI?
你希望它有机会达到最优。所以会有一些这方面的考虑，对吧？当然，这在 C++ 中会出现，因为这就是我们编写 C++ 的原因。还有，你知道，领域同理心，对吧？人们带着领域知识来到这里。你希望使用他们熟悉的术语。你希望以他们熟悉的方式使用它们。你很难来到一个领域，强加给你自己全新的视角和所有新的术语，并让人们接受它。例如，人们仍然在抱怨 Git 的 UI，对吧？Git 有 UI 吗？
Are we talking about like the... No, I'm totally... Well, yes, it has a... Not a graphical user interface, but as a user interface, yeah. I guess the six or seven Git commands that I, like, build my whole Git world off of are just terminal commands, and then every once in a while it shows me some, like, hashes or whatever, but... And at this point, you know, your own experience,
我们是在谈论……不，我完全……嗯，是的，它有一个……不是图形用户界面，但作为一个用户界面，是的。我想我用来构建整个 Git 世界的那六七个 Git 命令只是终端命令，然后偶尔它会向我展示一些哈希值之类的东西，但是……在这一点上，你知道，你自己的经验，
Git user, and so am I. We don't think twice about it. But, you know, in 2005, when we'd been using whatever... Perforce, Alien Brain, Source, Safe, even, you know, subversion, Git comes along and suddenly we're like, wait, that's not what checkout means. That's not what these terms mean. Git kind of redefined them all, and we had to relearn the Git way, right? I'm just saying that, you know, now in the case of Git, it was perhaps such a, such a sea change
Git 用户，我也是。我们不会多想。但是，你知道，在 2005 年，当我们一直在使用任何东西……Perforce、Alien Brain、SourceSafe，甚至，你知道，Subversion，Git 出现了，突然我们就像，等等，checkout 不是那个意思。这些术语不是那个意思。Git 重新定义了它们，我们不得不重新学习 Git 的方式，对吧？我只是说，你知道，现在在 Git 的例子中，这也许是一次巨大的变革，
in source control that that worked. But people still did complain about it, and people still, you know, people think, Git has a poor user interface. So anyway, that was all to say that you want to be sympathetic to the domain you're in, usually when crafting APIs. Yeah, I mean, I completely agree with that. But then it's like you said, just bringing up the, do you want to reinvent the world? Like, you know, the classic one is people complain about filter as an algorithm name or scan.
在源代码控制方面，这奏效了。但人们仍然抱怨它，人们仍然，你知道，人们认为 Git 的用户界面很差。所以，总之，我想说的是，在构建 API 时，你通常希望对你所处的领域有同理心。是的，我的意思是，我完全同意这一点。但就像你说的，提到这一点，你想重塑世界吗？比如，你知道，经典的一个例子是人们抱怨 filter 或 scan 作为算法名称。
Oh, yeah. Well, filter, does it mean, because does it mean positively or negatively? Is that that? Yeah. And some languages, I think, I don't know. It's either Scala or a Kotlin have literally like they have filter, but then they also have like alias for that called filter in, and then they have another filter out.
哦，是的。嗯，filter，它是什么意思？因为它是指正向还是负向？是那样吗？是的。在某些语言中，我想，我不知道。要么是 Scala 要么是 Kotlin，它们确实有 filter，但它们也有一个别名叫做 filterIn，然后它们还有另一个 filterOut。
Right. But like my kind of argument is like, well, when 98% of the programming languages out there agree on what filter means, you just have to kind of go with it. And it's less of a strong argument for scan, but most languages call, you know, cumulative folder reduction a scan.
对。但我的观点是，当 98% 的编程语言都同意 filter 的含义时，你只能顺应它。对于 scan 来说，这虽然不是一个强有力的论点，但大多数语言都把累积折叠归约称为 scan。
And so even though it, really is a terrible name. Like, scanning is much better for some kind of I.O. thing, which is what Java, they have like a scanner dot class that gets used all over the place. Oh, since we're on the subject things, I remember, so now I remember from your last podcast, you complained about the name of adjacent difference because, and that struck me as interesting because would you complain the same about partial sum? Yes. Okay. But then I thought, we are much more, well, I am much more, maybe you aren't, I am more willing to accept the idea of sum,
所以即使它确实是一个糟糕的名字。比如，scanning 对于某种 I/O 东西来说要好得多，这就是 Java 的做法，他们有一个 scanner 类，到处都在用。哦，既然我们谈到了这些事情，我记得，我现在从你上一期播客中记得，你抱怨 adjacent_difference 这个名字，因为，这让我觉得很有趣，因为你会同样抱怨 partial_sum 吗？是的。好吧。但我当时想，我们更愿意，嗯，我更愿意，也许你不是，我更愿意接受 sum 的概念，
meaning generic sum. Yes. And therefore, I'm also willing to accept the idea of difference meaning generic difference. But maybe you are different to me there. Well, I mean, just notably, you are the reason for, well, I mean, are you the sole reason, or, you know, 80% or whatever? But, I mean, I've brought this up multiple times on 80%.
意思是通用求和。是的。因此，我也愿意接受 difference 意味着通用差值的概念。但也许你在那方面和我不同。嗯，我的意思是，值得注意的是，你是原因，嗯，我的意思是，你是唯一的原因，还是，你知道，80% 之类的？但是，我的意思是，我多次提到过 80%。
that it was our conversation back in 2019 at C++ now. You were the one that pointed out to me that you didn't actually, I don't think, say my exact words of like encoding difference into the name is bad, but you pointed out that you could calculate Fibonacci numbers with adjacent difference. And then like I froze and I was like, no, you can't. And this was before I had given my talk. And then that like it led, I think it was 24 hours or 48 hours before my talk. And then I went and added like a whole four slides and then referenced that.
那是我们 2019 年在 C++ Now 上的谈话。是你向我指出，我不认为你说了我完全的原话，比如把差值编码进名字里是不好的，但你指出你可以用 adjacent_difference 计算斐波那契数列。然后我就愣住了，我说，不，你不能。这是在我做演讲之前。然后这导致，我想是在我演讲前 24 小时或 48 小时。然后我去加了整整四张幻灯片，然后引用了那个。
And I was like, this is terrible. Like, literally the name has prevented me. It provided a barrier that I was not able to hop over. And I'm sure many other people have. And it's tradeoff too, right? Do you, like, it became my view and is still my view that you should not bundle a default binary operation with a generic algorithm. That is my, and you can provide specializations.
我说，这太糟糕了。字面上看，这个名字阻碍了我。它提供了一个我无法跨越的障碍。我相信其他人也有过同样的经历。这也是一种权衡，对吧？你，比如，这成了我的观点，并且仍然是我的观点，你不应该将默认的二元操作与通用算法捆绑在一起。这是我的观点，你可以提供特化版本。
Like, I like what Q does. They have different deltas, which are, you know, minus adjacent difference. not equal adjacent difference. It's fine to provide specialized versions under different names, but I prefer the generic version. However, that is a harder thing to learn because you don't get like a working algorithm right off the bat. You have to go and figure out, oh, I got to go at a stud colon colon plus or a Lambda, which is like there's studies done that show that like Chinese kids learning Chinese master their numbering system faster
比如，我喜欢 Q 的做法。他们有不同的 deltas，也就是，你知道，减法 adjacent_difference。不是等于 adjacent_difference。提供不同名称的特化版本是可以的，但我更喜欢通用版本。然而，这更难学习，因为你不能直接得到一个现成的算法。你必须去弄清楚，哦，我得去加一个 std::plus 或者一个 Lambda，这就像有研究表明，学习中文的中国孩子掌握他们的数字系统更快，
because all of their numbers from zero to 10. The way you say the number is the number. Yeah. And it's also monosyllabic is the reason. So, like, kids trip up on seven in English because it's two syllables. And it takes longer to learn disyllabic words than it is to learn monosyllabic words. What about numbers in French? I mean, you're in Canada.
因为他们从 0 到 10 的所有数字。你读数字的方式就是那个数字。是的。而且它是单音节的，这就是原因。所以，比如，孩子们在英语中会被 7 绊倒，因为它是两个音节。学习双音节单词比学习单音节单词需要更长的时间。法语中的数字怎么样？我的意思是，你在加拿大。
You know some French, right? Numbers in French are very interesting. Have I ever whined? We may be going on a little tangent here. So, for those that don't know, I lived in China for over a year. It used to speak decently fluent Mandarin. And, you know, there's a quote. And I think it is actually about languages, not programming languages.
你会一点法语，对吧？法语中的数字非常有趣。我抱怨过吗？我们可能有点跑题了。所以，对于那些不知道的人，我在中国住了一年多。我曾经能说相当流利的普通话。而且，你知道，有一句名言。而且我认为它实际上是关于语言的，而不是编程语言。
That is, if you don't know one language until you know two and people have like reapplied that to programming languages. But boy, oh boy, is that a true quote when it applies to languages. I didn't understand how horrific a language English is, especially when it comes to the numbering system. And I apologize if I've told this story on this podcast before. But like the Chinese numbering system is perfect, is perfect. I love it.
那就是，如果你不知道两种语言，你就不知道一种语言，人们已经把这句话应用到编程语言上了。但是天哪，当它应用到语言上时，那真是一句真理。我不明白英语是多么可怕的一种语言，尤其是在数字系统方面。如果我之前在这个播客上讲过这个故事，我道歉。但是，比如中文数字系统是完美的，是完美的。我喜欢它。
I love it, folks. You've got zero to 10, you've got 100, you've got 1,000, and you've got 10,000. Everything else is math. And you're probably thinking, if you're an English speaker, which I assume most of our listeners are, I mean, that's... Hold on, hold on, hold on. You said it's perfect, but then you also said it's base 10. Is that? I mean, that makes sense for humans.
我喜欢它，伙计们。你有 0 到 10，你有 100，你有 1,000，你有 10,000。其他一切都是数学。如果你是一个英语母语者，我假设我们的大多数听众都是，你可能在想，我的意思是，那是……等等，等等，等等。你说它是完美的，但你也说它是 10 进制的。是吗？我的意思是，这对人类来说是有意义的。
Well, computers are base two. And, you know, I've been told that the optimal base is. base E. I've heard base six, I've heard base two. I've never heard base E. That's the first time. What's the argument for base E? Walter Brown had a lightning talk
嗯，计算机是 2 进制的。而且，你知道，有人告诉我最优的进制是 E 进制。我听说过 6 进制，我听说过 2 进制。我从没听说过 E 进制。那是第一次。E 进制的论点是什么？Walter Brown 有一个闪电演讲，
where he recounts the anecdote where he met I, no, I'm hopefully I'll get this. I think it was JV. Atanasoff. I think. Certainly someone from the early days of computing,
他在那里讲述了一个轶事，他遇到了 I，不，我希望我能说对。我想是 JV. Atanasoff。我想。当然是计算机早期时代的某个人，
some luminary that you would have heard of some name you would have heard of. And what? Walter being, I suppose, I don't know, an undergrad at the time, impertinently, somewhat impertinently, in his own words, asked why base two? Because, you know, back in the day, back in the 60s, it was, you know, it's not something we think about today, but it was a very valid question. Why did we go with base two? Why not, for example, I think some base three machines were, were around maybe, or certainly thought of, but everything now is, of course, base two. So anyway, he asked the question, which was perhaps a valid question, although in his own words, slightly important. And the reply was that it's a practical base to make machines from, right? And it's close enough to, and it's actually pretty good. But it's not optimal in terms of information theory, base E would be optimal apparently.
某个你会听说过的杰出人物，某个你会听说过的名字。然后呢？Walter 当时大概是一个本科生，用他自己的话说，冒昧地，有点冒昧地问为什么是 2 进制？因为，你知道，在那个年代，在 60 年代，你知道，这不是我们今天会想的事情，但这是一个非常有效的问题。为什么我们选择了 2 进制？为什么不是，例如，我想一些 3 进制机器可能存在，或者肯定被考虑过，但现在一切当然都是 2 进制。所以总之，他问了这个问题，这也许是一个有效的问题，尽管用他自己的话说，稍微有点冒昧。而回答是，这是一种制造机器的实用进制，对吧？而且它足够接近，而且实际上相当不错。但从信息论的角度来看，它不是最优的，显然 E 进制才是最优的。
It would be optimal based on information theory. Like, I got to say, I'm not smart enough to even know what that means. And also, too, I can't even conceptualize like base E. What I don't even, because the only bases I know. are like discrete integers. I don't actually know what does it mean to be irrational. You just, you have your units column, you have your X's column, your X squared's column, you know, you still have the place value system.
从信息论的角度来看，它将是最优的。比如，我得说，我甚至不够聪明，不知道那意味着什么。而且，我也无法概念化像 E 进制这样的东西。因为我唯一知道的进制是离散整数。我实际上不知道无理数意味着什么。你只是，你有你的单位列，你有你的 X 列，你的 X 平方列，你知道，你仍然有位值系统。
You just, your, your base is different at all. Interesting. Have you ever studied like base minus two? Negative bases? Have you read John Conway at all? This is, maybe I'm reading. I'm showing my, what do you call it, lack of, the lack of depth of my, books that I've read here now
你只是，你的进制在所有地方都不同。有趣。你研究过像 -2 进制吗？负进制？你读过 John Conway 的书吗？这，也许我正在读。我正在展示我的，你怎么说，缺乏深度，我读过的书在这里，
compared to you. But this is just, you know, this is an example of recreational mathematics. This is, let's make great, what's great about recreational mathematics
和你相比。但这只是，你知道，这是一个娱乐数学的例子。这是，让我们制造伟大的，娱乐数学的伟大之处在于
to bring it back to that. Oh, right. Anyway, so, yeah, Chinese numbers are very good. Let's say, better than English. If not perfect, very good
把它带回到那个话题。哦，对了。总之，是的，中文数字非常好。可以说，比英语好。如果不是完美的话，也非常棒，
for some situations anyway. And the reason is, is it's just math. It's just math, folks. And like I said, some of you might be thinking, what do you mean? English is just math too.
在某些情况下。原因就是，它只是数学。伙计们，它只是数学。就像我说的，你们有些人可能在想，你是什么意思？英语也只是数学。
No. most of the time it's math you know if you want to say the number 141 it's 100 40 and it's like what it's 40 in chinese it's 100 4101 we've got all these special words and you know what I can I can forgive 40 50 60 kind of you know what I can't forgive what I can't forgive what were people doing from numbers 11 to 19 11 and 12 like let's let's let's we'll get to 11 and 12 we've got 16 okay just adding team 17, 18, 19. Okay, you're just adding teen.
不。大多数时候它是数学，你知道，如果你想说数字 141，它是 100 40 1，这就像什么？中文里它是 100 4 10 1。我们有所有这些特殊的词，而且你知道吗，我可以原谅 40、50、60，你知道吗，我不能原谅什么？我不能原谅什么？人们在 11 到 19 的数字上做了什么？11 和 12，比如，让我们，让我们，我们会谈到 11 和 12，我们有 16，好的，只是加上 teen，17，18，19。好的，你只是加上 teen。
14. However, where's 3 teen and where's 15? We've got 13 and 15. It doesn't make any sense. We added teen and then for two of the numbers of the eight numbers, they just said we're going to modify it. And anyway, you might have the reason, but then they got to a... As my Latin teacher used to say, it makes sense.
14。然而，3 teen 在哪里？15 在哪里？我们有 13 和 15。这根本说不通。我们加上了 teen，然后对于八个数字中的两个，他们只是说我们要修改它。总之，你可能有原因，但后来他们到了……正如我的拉丁语老师过去常说的，它有道理。
You just can't make sense of it. I disagree. It doesn't make sense. Because at some point along the way, it evolved from some language where it did make sense, but then now it doesn't. So how do you make sense of it? Well, by the fact that millions of people around the world, hundreds of millions of people use it to count every day. Well, I mean, that's a bad argument. Just because it's what we know doesn't make it.
你只是无法理解它。我不同意。它没有道理。因为在某个时候，它从某种有道理的语言演变而来，但现在它没有了。那么你如何理解它呢？嗯，通过全世界数以亿计的人每天用它来计数的事实。嗯，我的意思是，那是一个糟糕的论点。仅仅因为它就是我们所知道的，并不意味着它……
That literally means that it makes sense. Now, making sense isn't necessarily mathematically the best, right? But, but, all right, now we're, okay, okay, so let me, let me walk my words back. Does it make, I mean, well, maybe I'll push back because does it make sense? Is that not a figure of speech? Doesn't mean what it literally means. You know, it's like, I've got a complaint about, but anyways, and 11 and 12 is just like, we're just out to lunch, you know?
那字面上意味着它有道理。现在，有道理并不一定在数学上是最好的，对吧？但是，但是，好吧，现在我们，好的，好的，所以让我，让我收回我的话。它有道理吗，我的意思是，嗯，也许我会反驳，因为它有道理吗？那不是一个比喻吗？它不意味着它字面上的意思。你知道，就像，我有一个抱怨，但无论如何，11 和 12 就像，我们只是出去吃午饭了，你知道？
It's like, what, there's 12 months in a year and therefore we got to do something special. Oh, why, why do you think everything has to be base 10? Well, it's not about, it's not about it being based. 10. It's about the corner cases that we are. You know, another, another mini tangent within this tangent is I read George Orwell's 1984, as I believe most kids do in high school, at least in Canada, if not in America and other countries. And yeah, take a bright cold day in April and read it. Yeah, yeah. It's my dad, a journalist, avid reader, avid writer, loves Orwell. One of his favorite quotes is, I'm going to butcher this, but roughly, I'm paraphrasing, is big ideas don't need big words and vice versa.
就像，什么，一年有 12 个月，因此我们必须做点特别的事情。哦，为什么，你为什么认为一切都必须是 10 进制？嗯，这不是关于，这不是关于它是基于 10 进制的。这是关于我们所处的边缘情况。你知道，在这个切线内的另一个，另一个小切线是我读了乔治·奥威尔的《1984》，我相信大多数孩子在高中时都会读，至少在加拿大是这样，如果不是在美国和其他国家的话。是的，在四月一个明亮寒冷的日子里读它。是的，是的。这是我爸爸，一位记者，狂热的读者，狂热的作家，热爱奥威尔。他最喜欢的名言之一是，我要把它搞砸了，但大致上，我是在转述，大思想不需要大词，反之亦然。
And he asked me when I finished reading that book what I thought. And I was like, well, I think they got some really good ideas in there. And he said, what? And I said, well, we got all these colorful words like fantastic, great. Their system seems to make a lot more sense. You got good, double good, triple good. Then you got great, double grade, triple great. And to me, in high school, that made a lot of sense.
当我读完那本书时，他问我怎么想。我说，嗯，我认为里面有一些非常好的想法。他说，什么？我说，嗯，我们有所有这些丰富多彩的词，比如 fantastic，great。他们的系统似乎更有道理。你有 good，double good，triple good。然后你有 great，double great，triple great。对我来说，在高中时，这非常有道理。
Because what is actually the difference between fantastic and marvelous and amazing? And when you reach for one of those words, are you actually able to describe why? Anyways, that was young me. I understand it's better to have a more colorful selection of language because it makes the language more beautiful. But at the time... Well, now, this is something where English beats everything else, right? Yes. English has synonyms.
因为 fantastic 和 marvelous 和 amazing 之间到底有什么区别？当你伸手去拿其中一个词时，你真的能描述原因吗？总之，那是年轻的我。我明白拥有更丰富多彩的语言选择更好，因为它使语言更美丽。但在当时……嗯，现在，这是英语胜过其他一切的地方，对吧？是的。英语有同义词。
Most languages flat out don't have synonyms pretty much. English, precisely because it is a massively confusing melting pot of languages over the years, we have synonyms, right? and close shades of meaning. Yeah. I have heard that. And that is what it makes, you know,
大多数语言几乎根本没有同义词。英语，正是因为它多年来是一个极其混乱的语言大熔炉，我们有同义词，对吧？以及细微的含义差别。是的。我听说过。这就是它所做的，你知道，
poetry in English and not that poetry and other languages isn't beautiful as well, but you can have evocative, whatever, sentences that, you know, choice words that hit people differently that you don't necessarily get
英语中的诗歌，并不是说其他语言的诗歌不美，但你可以有令人回味的，无论什么，句子，你知道，选择那些以不同方式触动人们的词，你未必能得到
in other languages. I can appreciate that now that I'm older. But young me was like, you know, you know, and probably you can now also live with contradictions, right?
在其他语言中。我现在老了，能欣赏这一点了。但年轻的我当时想，你知道，你知道，而且可能你现在也能忍受矛盾，对吧？
It doesn't, like, human language doesn't have to be perfect or even very precise or, you know, it doesn't have to have a system that can be explained in a few sentences. It's true that some, you know, particularly around orthography and things like that, you know, like a language like German, if you can, if you can spell it, you can say it pretty much all the time, right? when you read German, you just need to know how those letters in that form are pronounced, and there are vanishingly few exceptions. The same is, of course, not true of English.
它不需要，比如，人类语言不需要完美，甚至不需要非常精确，或者，你知道，它不需要有一个可以用几句话解释的系统。确实，有些，你知道，特别是在拼写等方面，你知道，像德语这样的语言，如果你能拼写它，你几乎总是能说出来，对吧？当你读德语时，你只需要知道那些字母在那种形式下是如何发音的，而且几乎没有例外。英语当然不是这样。
Yeah, that's one of my other huge complaints. There's a student when I was at in Hongzhou in China, and he pointed out his least favorite thing about the English language was the conjugation, the past tense conjugation of the word to read. And he's like, I read, I read. and he's like he's like it's one thing that from you know for my years those are almost like imperceptibly different it's a whole other thing that you didn't even change any of the letters in the conjugated word it's just the same word right it's spelt and he's like what kind of cruel joke
是的，这是我的另一个巨大抱怨。我在中国杭州时有一个学生，他指出他最不喜欢英语的一点是动词变位，单词 to read 的过去式变位。他说，I read，I read。他说，这就像，你知道，对我来说，那些几乎是难以察觉的区别，更别提你甚至没有改变变位词中的任何字母，它只是同一个词，对吧？它是拼写的，他说，你在跟我们开什么残酷的玩笑
are you playing on us like it's at least most you know I am I was you know they change it so you can tell here it's you pronounce it differently but it's not even not even they couldn't put one letter and I when I when he pointed that out I was I was like, oh my goodness, this is a, this is a cruel, terrible. And anyways, and this made me think of, I was going to say earlier, I also have a disdain for the uppercase and lowercase letters that exist in English. When I was in school, I always used to just write an uppercase letters and then make the beginning of a sentence slightly larger or the character of some word.
像这样，至少大多数，你知道，我曾经是，你知道，他们改变它，所以你可以分辨出这里你发音不同，但它甚至不是，甚至不是，他们不能放一个字母，当我，当他指出这一点时，我当时想，哦，天哪，这是一个，这是一个残酷的，可怕的。总之，这让我想起，我刚才想说，我也对英语中存在的大写和小写字母表示蔑视。我在学校时，总是只写大写字母，然后让句子的开头稍微大一点，或者某个单词的字符。
Because just why do we have both? You know, they say, they say it's for legibility, you know, the Js and the Gs. They go down below the line. But I just, I don't agree, you know, I don't agree. I mean, at some level, it's because of everything is because of history, right? It's because that's the way it's evolved over, you know, the last thousand years or whatever. Yeah. But I mean, that's, that, like, makes me think of, like, you know, how we have pedmas and bod mass or whatever you call it.
因为为什么我们两者都有？你知道，他们说，他们说这是为了可读性，你知道，J 和 G。它们在行下方。但我只是，我不同意，你知道，我不赞同。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这是因为一切都是因为历史，对吧？这是因为它在过去一千年左右的时间里就是这样演变的。是的。但我的意思是，那，就像，让我想起，比如，你知道，我们有 PEMDAS 和 BODMAS 或者无论你叫它什么。
Right. And that just, I remember, I did this for the rest of my life, I will remember being in a meeting and a senior person. because I pointed out that it was just, obviously that's just ridiculous. Like, why do we still have this like an APL in small talk, several other languages? It's just linear. It's just linear.
对。而那只是，我记得，我余生都会记得在一次会议上，一位资深人士。因为我指出这只是，显然这太荒谬了。比如，为什么我们仍然有这个，像 APL 和 Smalltalk，其他几种语言？它只是线性的。它只是线性的。
Why do we have this? It's insane. We built a hierarchy of precedence attached to a subset of the binary and unary operations out there. And, you know, technically if you Google, if you go to the Wikipedia page and you ask for where's the FFTA, where's factorial, it actually, they do have a Puffet mask somewhere where they put the F in. And it like, but it only stuff. Anyways.
为什么我们有这个？这太疯狂了。我们建立了一个优先级层次结构，附加到现有的二元和一元操作的子集上。而且，你知道，从技术上讲，如果你用谷歌搜索，如果你去维基百科页面并询问 FFTA 在哪里，阶乘在哪里，他们实际上确实在某个地方有一个 PEMDAS，他们把 F 放进去了。而且它只是东西。总之。
And the scene. your person said, it's what they taught in schools, therefore it's correct. It's what we all know. And I was just like, are you kidding me? That's not just because like history has got us to this point doesn't make it like the best. Anyway, so, you know, everywhere we are today is yes defined by history. I mean, I feel compelled to take the other side. Yes, yes, yes. Please do. Which is to say that for most people, most of the time, it's just fine. There is no compelling reason to change. And while there might be
而那位资深人士说，这是他们在学校教的，因此它是正确的。这是我们都知道的。我当时想，你在开玩笑吗？那不是，仅仅因为历史把我们带到了这一点，并不意味着它是最好的。总之，你知道，我们今天所处的每一个地方都是由历史定义的。我的意思是，我感到有义务站在另一边。是的，是的，是的。请务必这样做。也就是说，对大多数人来说，大多数时候，这都很好。没有令人信服的理由去改变。虽然可能存在
purer ways to do things, better ways to do things when talking to a machine, perhaps, you know, going to quote, is it Gerald Sussman? Code should be written for humans to read and only incidentally for machines to execute. I mean, I'm not
更纯粹的做事方式，更好的做事方式，当与机器交谈时，也许，你知道，引用，是 Gerald Sussman 吗？代码应该为人类阅读而编写，只是顺便为机器执行而编写。我的意思是，我并不
convinced by that. For most people, it's good enough. I mean, this kind of, one of the other things in the topic list that I sent was this kind of, I mean, I'm not sure who originated it, or maybe it's not something that can be originated by one person. But I actually tried to look it up, but unfortunately, I asked Gemini, because Gemini has, I assume all the YouTube video transcripts encoded in their models. And I said, what YouTube video did Dave Abrams give a talk in where he was talking about trying to find, like one of his kind of North Stars in his work and whatnot is trying to find algorithmic truth?
被那个说服。对大多数人来说，这就足够了。我的意思是，这有点，我发送的主题列表中的另一件事是这种，我的意思是，我不确定是谁发起的，或者也许这不是一个人可以发起的。但我实际上试着查了一下，但不幸的是，我问了 Gemini，因为 Gemini 有，我假设所有 YouTube 视频的转录都编码在他们的模型中。我说，Dave Abrahams 在哪个 YouTube 视频中做过演讲，他在谈论试图找到，比如他工作中的北极星之一之类的，是试图找到算法真理？
I swear I've heard someone, I thought it was him. use that exact quote unquote like algorithmic truth. And, you know, he always refers to Stepanov in his talks. And when I think of people that talk about that idea, I think of Sean Parent, you, Dave Abraham's and Alex Stepanov. Anyways, somewhere out there, someone said it. And they pointed me at a, or Gemini pointed me at a C++ now 2020 talk, I think, or four talk, where it was part one of two of value-oriented programming or something like that. And he does mention truth and generic programming, but it wasn't the exact talk. And I'm pretty sure it's because it was one of his algorithm talks that he's given at WWDC,
我发誓我听过有人，我以为是他。使用那个确切的引用，比如“算法真理”。而且，你知道，他在演讲中总是提到 Stepanov。当我想到谈论那个想法的人时，我想到 Sean Parent，你，Dave Abrahams 和 Alex Stepanov。总之，在某个地方，有人说了它。他们指引我到一个 C++ Now 2020 演讲，我想，或者 2004 演讲，它是价值导向编程的第一部分或类似的东西。他确实提到了真理和泛型编程，但那不是确切的演讲。而且我很确定是因为那是他在 WWDC 上做过的算法演讲之一，
but those have kind of disappeared off the internet and they don't live on YouTube. And I bring this up because when you say it's good enough for most people, I guess that's kind of... I am not saying... I'm not saying that it is good enough for all use cases, right? What I'm saying is conventions matter, I guess. I'm not saying it's not a noble pursuit to try and, you know,
但那些已经从互联网上消失了，它们没有留在 YouTube 上。我提出这一点是因为当你说是大多数人足够好时，我想那有点……我不是说……我不是说它对所有用例都足够好，对吧？我所说的是约定很重要，我想。我不是说尝试，你知道，
and be aware that I'm purposefully taking this side of the argument. There's not necessarily represent what I do every day, but it is part of it. Like, I do feel this. It is and it's fine to look for new and better ways of doing things, but also at the end of the day, we have to be able to communicate with people. Some fields require extra precision. It's true. But my argument is like the convention of Bodmas
并意识到我正在有目的地站在论点的这一边，这不是必然代表我每天所做的事情，但它是其中的一部分。比如，我确实感觉到了这一点。它是，而且寻找新的和更好的做事方式是可以的，但归根结底，我们必须能够与人交流。有些领域需要额外的精度。这是真的。但我的论点是，像 BODMAS 的约定
or please excuse my dear aunt Sally, things like that. I've never heard of that. I think that's the American thing people get taught. But that's also, you know, there's more than what people get taught. That is a convention that mathematicians use to read things. Like, obviously, they don't have to think about it consciously all the time. But in writing out equations, that there are conventions. And if it's not hemmed as, it's something else, right?
或者 Please Excuse My Dear Aunt Sally 之类的东西。我从来没听说过那个。我想那是美国人被教的东西。但那也是，你知道，不仅仅是人们被教的东西。那是数学家用来阅读事物的约定。比如，显然，他们不必一直有意识地思考它。但在写出方程式时，确实有约定。如果不是 PEMDAS，那就是别的东西，对吧？
I mean, this is a very, I mean, we're kind of off on a tangent. But this is a very, yeah, this is a very interesting, so, you know, to strap in, listener because this I find this topic this conversation this is exactly what you and I would be talking about if we were at some conference after a long day of talks yeah yeah we would be having this conversation because it makes me think of two things so you know you said convention matters I don't I don't disagree that being said you know a part of Iverson's goal creating APL which became a language but at first was just a notation it was a thing that he used for teaching algorithms and on chalkboards.
我的意思是，这是一个非常，我的意思是，我们有点跑题了。但这确实是一个，这是一个非常有趣的话题，所以，你知道，系好安全带，听众，因为我发现这个话题，这个对话，这正是你和我如果在一场漫长的演讲后在某个会议上会谈论的内容。是的，是的，我们会进行这次谈话，因为它让我想起两件事：所以，你知道，你说约定很重要，我不不同意。话虽如此，你知道，Iverson 创建 APL 的目标的一部分，它成为了一种语言，但起初只是一种符号，它是他用于教学算法和在黑板上使用的东西。
And he was, he looked at the state of notation across subdomains and mathematics linear algebra, calculus, et cetera. And was just like, what are we doing here? What are we doing here? You know, this is not, you cannot tell me that this is the epitome of mathematical communication, you know, and I've whined about many of these things, the fact that we give symbols to certain binary operations. But then we, we just stop.
而且他，他观察了数学、线性代数、微积分等子领域中符号的状态。然后就像，我们在这里做什么？我们在这里做什么？你知道，这不是，你不能告诉我这是数学交流的缩影，你知道，而且我抱怨过很多这些事情，我们给某些二元操作赋予符号的事实。但后来我们，我们只是停下来了。
We stop short. Where's the symbol for men? Where's the symbol for max? You know, we've got a notation for a reduction for summation with the capital sigma. We've got one for product with capital pi. And we just stopped there. We just stopped there. Those are the only two important enough.
我们停下来了。min 的符号在哪里？max 的符号在哪里？你知道，我们有用于归约的符号，用于求和的资本 Sigma。我们有用于乘积的资本 Pi。而我们只是停在那里。我们只是停在那里。那些是唯一足够重要的。
Don't get me wrong. Those are probably the two most common reductions, maybe the most too common. So if you're only going to choose two, you probably choose those two. But I actually would actually push back on that, though, because how often are you doing a product? You probably do a min and a max reduction more than you do a multiplication reduction. Food for thought. Proof of thought. Maybe not in finance because you're doing like 1.01, but if you're actually doing integers, you overflow very quickly. Anyways, the point being, he took a look at the state of the art and was like, we can do better. And that's what he tried to do. It never caught on. And then when that thought process went through my head, what you're talking about here also kind of like attaches to why Python and JavaScript, which many people, not necessarily no one, would argue that those are not the perfect or best. Even if there is such a thing, if you're going to rank them, is it like, you know, the language you would reach for.
别误会我的意思。那些可能是两个最常见的归约，也许是最常见的两个。所以如果你只能选择两个，你可能会选择那两个。但我实际上会反驳这一点，因为你多久做一次乘积？你做 min 和 max 归约的次数可能比做乘法归约的次数多。值得深思。值得深思。也许在金融领域不是，因为你在做 1.01 之类的，但如果你实际上是在做整数，你会很快溢出。总之，重点是，他看了一眼最先进的技术，觉得我们可以做得更好。这就是他试图做的。它从未流行起来。然后当那个思维过程在我脑海中闪过时，你在这里谈论的内容也某种程度上与为什么 Python 和 JavaScript，许多人，未必没有人，会争辩说那些不是完美的或最好的。即使有这样的东西，如果你要对它们进行排名，它是否像，你知道，你会伸手去拿的语言。
You know, a lot of people say that Python is the second best language for everything, but not the best language for everything, yet it's still very popular. Right. And I have come over time to have more sympathy for that, like, actually maybe Python really has done something, like, really well. Even if it's not great for the programming language enthusiasts and programming language implementers,
你知道，很多人说 Python 是每件事的第二好语言，但不是每件事的最好语言，然而它仍然非常流行。对。随着时间的推移，我对这一点有了更多的同情，比如，实际上也许 Python 真的做了一些，比如，非常好的事情。即使它对编程语言爱好者和编程语言实现者来说不是很好，
there's a reason people reach for it. And... Yeah. What Python does well is it meets people where they are, right? Python is a language you can write without knowing Python. All you need to know is what you want to do to instruct the computer and the barest of syntax. And you basically write your pseudo code
人们伸手去拿它是有原因的。而且……是的。Python 做得好的是它在人们所在的地方满足他们，对吧？Python 是一种你可以在不知道 Python 的情况下编写的语言。你只需要知道你想做什么来指导计算机，以及最基本的语法。你基本上写你的伪代码，
and it turns out that Python's fine with that. So you don't have to learn a lot. Yes. And then of course later on, you can learn things which are more pythonic or better or somewhere. But fundamentally, it meets people where they are. Yeah, it's the steepness of the, on ramp or the learning curve to your first line of Python and your first small working program
结果 Python 对此没问题。所以你不需要学习很多。是的。然后当然以后，你可以学习更符合 Python 风格的或更好的东西。但从根本上说，它在人们所在的地方满足他们。是的，通往你的第一行 Python 和你的第一个小型工作程序的坡道或学习曲线的陡峭程度
is very, very... So shallow. Yeah. If imperceptible, you know, like compared to something like APL or C++ plus or Java back in the day when you did. We have to figure out to set up a tool chain or, you know, figure out what the glyphs mean. Yes. And so I think that there is, there's a lot of, I don't know, truth or wisdom to be found.
是非常，非常……如此平缓。是的。如果难以察觉，你知道，比如与像 APL 或 C++ 或 Java 在过去你做的时候相比。我们必须弄清楚如何设置工具链，或者，你知道，弄清楚字形是什么意思。是的。所以我认为，有，有很多，我不知道，真理或智慧可以被发现。
and like, why is Python and why is JavaScript? Why are they so popular, even though people have so many complaints about them? And so I, in one sense, I agree that, you know, this being able to communicate, there are other things other than like the perfect language or, you know, whatever, whatever my North Star, you know, algorithmic truth. There's more, there's other things. It's not that that's not important. That being said, I don't know, I guess, you know, part of this like recreational algorithms,
比如，为什么 Python 和为什么 JavaScript？为什么它们如此流行，即使人们对它们有这么多抱怨？所以我，在某种意义上，我同意，你知道，这种能够交流的能力，除了像完美的语言或，你知道，无论什么，无论我的北极星，你知道，算法真理。还有更多，还有其他事情。并不是说那不重要。话虽如此，我不知道，我想，你知道，这种像娱乐算法的一部分，
this topic overall and the playfulness and truth is like I don't know there's the language that I think in and the vocabulary that I use is all like rooted in array languages at all like that is the best thing I found out there and even a lot of these array languages I have small issues with be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions thanks for listening we You hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
总的来说，这个话题以及其中的趣味性和真实性，我不知道，我思考时所用的语言和词汇，全都植根于数组语言，那是我发现的最好的东西。即使是这些数组语言中的很多，我也有些小意见。请务必查看播客应用或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上的节目说明，获取我们今天提到的所有内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望您喜欢，祝您有愉快的一天。我是反括号。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。